first time you met manny you uh
like you were like okay like i want to
get bitten by a rattlesnake
man he says you can't do that
right and you're like really pushing for
it no like just let the rattlesnake bite
me
and we learned that when manny
says uh
no
that means [ __ ] no yeah yeah if
manny's sketchy about it then it's like
all right all right because when manny
says yes that doesn't necessarily mean
you're good
what was that when you were getting you
were before the uh you're hanging out
over the alligator pit and what was your
safety plan
he says if an alligator gets a hold of
stevo stevo will relax and hopefully the
alligator will release him
[Laughter]
he's so great i remember like one of the
it might have been the first time i ever
filmed with with uh manny when we went
out to do the hammerhead thing it was
the first well the first day on the with
sharks and manny and uh
they chopped barracuda
in half and and strung them all up and
like bloody and just
chum
chopped up barracuda fish strapped all
over me
and and then manny put me in the water
with the sharks
yeah and i remember at my dad's side and
my dad says how could it possibly be
safe to be covered in chum swimming with
sharks and i looked at dad like
dad manny was there god
yeah [ __ ]
manny's like my little uh force field
yeah that's how i feel about uh
gary lefew with the ball i mean i feel
that way about manny too he's he he's
he's tarzan right right and you do feel
even though you're doing something
[ __ ]
you do feel like somewhat safe just
because he's there
and the same way with gary lefew with
bulls for sure uh
i just always feel like he's well he
always he's always got my back and he
always has he hires the best bull
fighters uh because they're crucial
because if you go you get ko
and uh you're alone in the ring with the
bull it it could be even worse
yeah for sure there was a time where
everyone's going to know this with manny
we put the fish hook through my face
and cast me out to the sharks manny's
manny's chopping up the you know he's
just
chumming the water treading water
hacking up fish
and he sees this maker shark going after
me like it's gonna bite my foot and one
of the very few times manny ever became
uncomfortable while filming like i heard
he screams stephen watch out right and
and
i hear that and so i'm like [ __ ] i i
panic and i go to like you know kick and
to go swim away and in that motion i
inadvertently kick the maker shark in
the head as it's going for my foot yeah
which was like arguably one of the
closest calls i've ever had yeah and and
i think
it was like years later i asked jeff
tremaine i said jeff dude if that maker
sharp bit my foot
we were
two hours away from the the coast of
hurricane katrina devastated louisiana
like what the [ __ ] was the plan like
like a helicopter i mean like what and
and tremaine said oh we didn't have a
plan we got god
like how do you explain how lucky we've
been
when i was in arkansas getting ready to
do the riot control test
and i was talking to jeff and
talking about casting you out to sea
with the hook through your mouth chummed
up waters with sharks
and i was like jeff what what is the uh
how does what what's the best case
scenario of this because
how's it going i mean if we get footage
that means something terrible has
happened
and
how do we air that like what are we
going for here and he's like oh no it'll
be great i'm like
i really had questions about that so it
was one of those things where right it
couldn't have went any better like you
didn't get hurt but you almost got
annihilated you almost were missing the
foot right i mean like it's like great
jeffy you've explained the the beginning
in the middle but yeah
at the end there's only one way for this
to end for it to air right i remember
being troubled by that bit but i wasn't
so troubled that i said don't do it
i did i did have pause i was thinking of
your steve
right yeah and it was the same thing
with the alligator tightrope i i as i
understood it my job for the alligator
tightrope i was like oh yeah and then
tomorrow i'm getting bit by an alligator
like i'm gonna walk on the table fall
off and then in the alligator pit and
then i get bit
yeah
yeah
and that was another one i remember
feeling like not getting bit by the
alligator and it just taking the chicken
out of the jog strap
to me that like felt the way you
described getting on a social bowl i was
like oh man like you know i've lost my
respect i showed up to get attacked by
an alligator no no but that was great
you didn't hey
cause you could have yeah you very well
could have and you stuck it out and you
did all you needed to do
yeah so i mean that's a great bit yeah
and in hindsight i'm not i'm not upset
about it but uh but i remember thinking
oh i really got away with one today yeah
yeah
um what uh
yeah what what are some of the other
like just crazy like where we've got
angels i mean i i i think about dragons
i really believe that the rock the
rocket for the rocket yeah it not only
almost killed me but one rocket goes out
back like
150 yards and goes right between
kassick and scott manning's ear is just
shut and that would have decapitated one
of them or both of them it was a foot
long metal rod
that was an angel um the the steel wall
falling on me at the end of jackass
number two
because the the guy who rigged it is
like
you get to your mark don't move it's a
this is a this is a steel wall you will
die if it hits you
and then
what happened that's like travis
pastrana telling you not to let go of
the bike
i'm not listening like before i do a
stunt i don't sometimes i i you can be
talking to me but you can see in my eyes
that i'm far away
you know
i remember seeing the wall hit you
thinking like that was
that was the bit you know like no no
that wasn't supposed to happen wow and
uh
i remember on the set
i had
uh my daughter come down because i
thought this is like no one's going to
get hurt today we're just
it's pretty casual and then at that door
that steel wall slammed me and it goes
silent on the set except for madison and
she goes
dad what are you doing you idiot
everyone started laughing after that
because
you know i moved around a little so oh
wow yeah and like the the golf cart with
uh yeah that could have been that was
almost real bad yeah
that was
i feel like for
for years after that the golf cart was
referred to as the incident
yeah like
that good because that one was really
really scary but yeah we've been we've
been incredibly fortunate man we've had
a lot of incidents
yeah dude